we're talking about curation today and I
think one way to describe minimalism is
minimalism is a well curated life yeah I
wanted to talk to you because I don't
like just finding articles that back up
my points but I sent you this article
this week about this one this one's from
Bloomberg it's an op-ed piece by Tyler
Cohen and it's called American zone less
stuff and that's reason to be nervous
first off I totally disagree and I think
most data will actually back up that we
don't own less stuff what he means is we
have access to more things like Kindle
books as opposed to physical book we
have less of a need for ownership less
of a need for ownership of physical item
right it's like no longer do I need a
cassette right when I can I can have the
album in my pocket or any medieval
exactly yeah so let's read this and
let's let's try to talk talk about it
and we'll pick it apart a little bit
because I think this applies to the
topic of curation and how we can have a
well curated life I think some of it has
to do with access so here's the Tyler
Cohen says some social problems are
blatantly obvious in daily life while
others are longer-term more corrosive
and perhaps mostly invisible lately I've
been worrying about a problem of the
latter kind the erosion of personal
ownership and what that will mean for
our loyalties of traditional American
concepts of capitalism and private
property the main culprits for the
change are software and the internet for
instance Amazon's Kindle and other
methods of online reading have
revolutionized how Americans consume
text fifteen years ago people typically
owned the books and magazines they were
reading much less so now if you look at
the fine print it turns out that you do
not own the books on your Kindle
amazon.com Inc does and and my response
to that is so what like yeah that's like
it's like iTunes music I mean we spend
10 bucks a month we don't own the music
if we ever cancel that subscription we
lose
the albums that we downloaded right I
mean yeah it's but it yeah but so so
think about like you and I used to get
like GQ magazine in the mail right and
moving my basement I had like big bins
full of old gqueues I had ownership of
them yeah but the value isn't in the
ownership of the artifact to me the
value is in the words themselves if
you're getting value from the book you
can evaluate for the magazine article
you get value from the music it's not
because you own that CD it's because you
enjoy listening to that and I am I've
become vehicle agnostic I don't care
whether it's on a CD Island one CD it's
parler hawk second album parler hawk and
it's in my car like I cuz my car has one
CD slot and so is that not on strength
the streaming platforms or it may not be
I know I have a downloaded version of it
but andrew is the one who did the
soundtrack to the lead singer of our of
our of that band did the soundtrack to
our first documentary and the good news
is they're gonna start working on the
we'll talk about this later but yeah
working on the soundtrack for the second
documentary anyway back to the article
here I do not consider this much of a
practical problem yeah yeah me either
although Amazon could obliterate the
books on my Kindle this has happened
only in a very small number of cases
typically involving account abuse okay
so if someone's abusing the the terms of
the Kindle of course they could
obliterate it it's not however in
Amazon's interest to randomly go in and
delete your Kindle collection right or
start messing with you and saying I
don't want Ryan to read you know
Infinite Jest alright and remove this
from his Kindle so he reads Fifty Shades
of Grey still this licensing of e-books
instead of stacking books on a shelf has
altered our psychological sense of how
we connect to what we read it's no
longer truly ours hmm good yeah that's
awesome
that is great yeah because what really
what he's saying is as alter our
psychological sense of how we can
connect to what we read connect to what
we need
you know I would say no it allows us to
more easily detach from physical
ownership of artifacts that aren't
adding value to our lives
because it's up there in the cloud you
think of an album that you bought over a
decade ago but haven't listened to since
oh yeah absolutely mean dude I had when
I was digitizing DVDs and CDs like I
remember I had that you know 100 200
book of CDs and like a lot of them are
like burnt CDs that you know that
someone had given me and I just had like
the songs listed out but I remember just
like going through the I probably 350 of
them away because you know well the the
vast reason why was because I was not
listening to those you know two three
quarters of those CDs right I didn't see
myself listening to them in the near
future and if they're in the cloud it's
easy to let go of them because you know
you'll still have access to them in the
future if you do want to break out that
Abba album and you want to listen to it
then then you can but if you don't then
you don't and that's okay you've
detached from it yeah this technology is
enable us to detach more easily and I
think that's such a great thing dude you
hit the nail on the head with the
experience is what we get joy out of
right and we used to have to own these
things in order to access that
experience yes and dude it I mean it
wasn't that long ago 20 years ago so so
over the last 20 years I mean we have
been evolving to less ownership and more
access and you know I think this is just
a this article is a reaction to change
it's a reaction to this evolution that
is that is happening man but but again
those those experiences that we want
with a CD with a book yeah dude like we
don't have to own a physical copy we can
access it anytime yeah and I'm not
against ownership I heard some physical
books I own a car but I also have access
to more books on my Kindle and I also
have access to lyft or uber if I if I
want to or those little bird scooters or
whatever like there are other means of
transportation or the subway system here
you know I have the ability to have
access to things will help without
having to own every room you don't have
a home gym in your home you have access
to the equipment that other people share
you don't have to own every single
weight that's in your gym because I know
you lift all the way all right
yeah and and weights out of the back to
add more weight anyway back to this
article here the change in our
relationship with physical objects does
not stop there we used to buy DVDs or
video cassettes now viewers stream
movies or TV shows with Netflix good
that is great I feel like an 85 year old
like angry big money
yeah wrote this yeah yeah and I feel
like his father may have written like an
article about you know how he was mad
that eight tracks were turning into
cassette tapes or something right even
the company's disc mailing service is
falling out of favor good what would I
do with a DVD if you mailed one to me a
you your mailing something to me so
you're wasting all this packaging and
and by the way it's gonna take more
people to ship the thing and yeah the
environments will costs alone yeah not
worth it absolutely and so yes it's
falling out of favor good if you sent me
a DVD I would have to go buy a DVD
player to play it right I don't want to
have to do that yeah music lovers used
to buy compact discs now Spotify and
YouTube are more commonly used to hear
our favorite tunes yeah huh I have
access to all I don't have to carry
around this damn CD booklet or I used to
have a 50 disc CD changer in my trunk
yeah and it's crazy
you know I've OCD so I knew where all
what was in all 50 this oh yeah it was
alphabetized
[Laughter]
the great American Teenage Dream used to
be to own your own car that is dwindling
in favor of urban living greater
reliance on mass transit cycling walking
and of course ride-sharing services such
as uber and
you know this or this whole article it
just made me think of like how so you
look at Millennials and they get such a
bad rap dude yeah they get such a bad
all they're lazy they don't want to buy
stuff anymore they don't want to have to
own a CD they were I mean this sounds
like it is I know they're not
specifically targeting Millennials but
it could be but they are by proxy by
proxy they are and here's the thing man
is that people nowadays especially
Millennials they want meaning in their
life they want to do something that is
purposeful they are not after oh I'm
going to get a job I'm going to have a
wife and two point three kids and I'm
going to have a my own piece of land and
maybe if I get rich enough I can have my
own theater I can have all these things
to pacify me I mean that is that is what
what we have done as a culture over you
know past post-industrial age it's how
much stuff can we get how many pacifiers
can we bring into our lives right and
ultimately man that's what I hear this
article saying is it is people are
cutting back on their pacifiers per say
and yeah it's a good thing man or or
also people are sharing more frequent
right how's that again I go back to the
gym analogy right there was a time if
you wanted exercise equipment there was
not generally a local place to go to
work out or if there was it was far away
and now there's access to gyms and
pretty much every small town even we
lived in Missoula Montana there's
probably 10 15 20 different gyms there
dude yeah I mean it had the nicest gym I
mean with Marv and I we belonged to like
the one of the nicest gyms in LA and
when I say it's nice it is it's clean
you know awesome staff some pretty cool
amenities the leg that is doesn't even
touch what we had in Missoula anyway
yeah that was a little bit of a tangent
well III think the the nice thing the
nice thing is imagine how much would
cost you to buy everything you use
Jim yeah tens of thousands of dollars
yeah I mean we're and by the way then
you'd also need the space to fill it and
you you'd be the one taking care of it
and you'd be washing the towels and I
mean all of these additional costs and
so I say good to all of us
each of these changes is beneficial yet
I worried that Americans are slowly but
surely losing their connection to the
idea of private ownership here's why I
disagree with this
so SoulCycle class you and I have gotten
the SoulCycle we talked about it last
week on the podcast I after going to
SoulCycle several times realize I'd like
to do this more frequently but I would
like to do it when it's appropriately
time for me and so backs and I after a
month or two months actually of doing
research and planning and making sure
that we could afford it we bought a soul
cycle bike basically one this is
actually better than you would use in a
soul cycle class because it has like
monitors and stuff but what I've got
like the workouts on the monitors yes
yeah yeah and and also but it tells you
what your resistance is what your
cadence is oh it sounded like just a
little knob really yeah this feels right
you use the knob right and they'll tell
you like you coach your resistance is
thirty five now we're gonna move that
resistance up to 55 and so it's actually
more helpful than the SoulCycle class
for me but it's more helpful also
because I can use it like if I want to
use it at seven o'clock in the morning
or whenever and I don't have to leave
the house to do it yeah and I'm doing it
much more frequently as a result right
now the problem with that is a lot of
people well you and I talked about the
Seth Godin thing where his grandma
bought the exercise equipment and she
thought it would do the work for her II
am that's often the problem we have with
a lot of ownership and so having access
to that SoulCycle class was the reason
that I brought this new bike into my
life I wouldn't have brought it into my
life otherwise because I would like I'm
not really sure I'm not sure if I'm
going to use it but once I started going
this whole cycle like oh this has
beneficial to me but I want a way to be
able to do this in my house daily or
every other day
then I decided to own the thing because
it made sense for me the same thing with
with car ownership I owned a car because
it makes sense for me it doesn't make
sense for everyone and if it doesn't
make sense for you I applaud you I say
that's great if I lived in Manhattan it
would it would be a burden for me to own
a car I'd rather have access and share
that access with everyone yeah yeah just
like you said man it sounds like we're
going more towards a sharing community
yeah the there's nothing wrong with
private ownership that's we certainly
aren't against that as you just
expressed with your with your exercise
bike but it you know it can it can get
dangerous with things like well you know
nowadays like people want their own home
theater mm-hmm like you used to go to
the theater and it was an experience and
you got out you would see you know
people in the community I mean it's not
a very interactive experience with the
community but it was this way it was
this thing that would you know bring the
community together a little bit more now
you know people want to have their own
private home theater and that is the
that type of private ownership it could
just pull us away from being engaged
engaging with the community so I again
dude I totally love that we're heading
towards a sharing community yeah yeah
sure ah market the nation was based on
the notion that private ownership gives
individuals a stake in the system I
don't agree with that but we'll talk
with her moment read that sentence again
the nation was based on the notion that
private ownership gives individuals a
stake in the system Wow I don't think
that's what gave individuals at stake in
the system I think we we come from a
relative Puritan upbringing our country
does and the stake in the system was
always hard work right right and yeah I
think and and now well I like to see the
shift go toward instead of hard work is
meaningful work absolutely dude well you
know what though man
the that stake in the system with with
ownership with private ownership of
something that is like a false sense of
having a stake it's like it's like I
don't know I could liken it to on the
day where maybe I don't get a whole
a lot done but I've caught up on email
and you know I've caught up on social
media and I feel like I got something
done today but really didn't really get
anything done there's nothing meaningful
when we are just catching up on things
that's what yeah that's another way say
to men is it might be maybe it is a
stake in in our society but it's not a
very meaningful stake in our society
yeah yeah exactly
someone tweeted me recently are treated
at the minimalists and said well I I
disagree with the basically they said
something about I find this coffee mug
that I have to be so meaningful awesome
and and like they said in a way that was
almost like belligerent and like you
guys are totally wrong I find my coffee
mug to be meaningful and you know my
response was well then you know when you
die you should ask your family to bury
you with it I mean because here's the
truth that we can't we can't bring we
don't own anything ultimately right like
we're just renting for the 80 years that
we are here yeah and then maybe we can
pass those rentals on to a future
generation or whatever and that's what
we want to talk about today is is what
does it mean to to curate so we're gonna
get back to this or over here it said
Americans apart from feudal peasants
taught us how property rights and
incentives operate totally disagree
about that incentives operate not via
physical goods but we're incentivize to
do all kinds of things that have nothing
to do with private property or physical
ownership of physical goods yeah in fact
we don't pay people like it like podcast
Shawn or Jordan no more over here we
don't you know W more yeah okay yeah
Jordan no more I and we don't pay them
in physical goods right hey did you
imagine here's a Casio watch this is
pretty
weeks worth of work and Shawn here is a
jar of jellybeans right Shawn would like
podcast I would love that jellybeans
yeah he would his his daughter's like
just take it from him anyway so yeah we
we don't we incentivize them not I don't
think if we don't give them physical
money even right you 90 over 90 percent
of the the money that that's in our
country is digitized as well it's zeros
and one right they're incentivized by
zeros and ones and it's what those other
zeros and ones get them and quite often
it's not the physical good it could be
Spotify or whatever right yeah you're
paying for Spotify with the zeros and
ones that we gave you and it was a kind
of training for future entrepreneurship
no today's entrepreneurs are often
selling services not physical goods mmm
do we not as parents give our children
pets or other valuable possessions to
teach them the basic lessons of life and
stewardship no I've never given a pet
teacher stewardship we're hardly at a
point where Americans properly property
has been abolished but I am still
nervous that we are finding ownership to
be so inconvenient again yes we're
talking about convenience the
convenience economy the access economy
the reason that we live in a city is you
walked here today you didn't have to
take a car dude ownership is
inconvenient
quite often it is dude and sometimes it
is convenient we just yeah yeah
sometimes but like we just moved Mariah
and I just moved to a new apartment and
I mean it took the movers for hours like
from time of picking up our stuff to
going 30 minutes across town stopping a
podcast Sean's place to drop off a
mattress that we didn't need anymore
mm-hmm then go in our place and loading
everything up to our place it took them
four hours that's convenient man yeah
and and can you imagine if you were
Colin right he can move in four minutes
right and because he's not
inconvenienced by all the stuff right
yawns fifty-two items or whatever it is
and and that's it by the way check out
Colin right on tour becoming tour.com
owning a car is inconvenient man I mean
if I could do a rideshare everywhere I
went it wasn't ungodly expensive I'd do
that in LA having a car makes it a
little bit better a little less
expensive getting from point A to point
B but ultimately dude I hate owning a
car I got to change the oil in the thing
clean the thing I got a there's so many
other other aspects of owning a car
besides just parking it in my garage and
then losing I need it yeah surance and
all now I've got I don't know so in you
member a little rough spot those on the
passenger yeah a passenger inside of the
back door it uh it is like there's
nothing there not because of the salt
from the ocean it's just like a matter
of time before I think I got to do
something I gave you got to replace the
door I don't know I gotta do something
about it but anyway but just that one
thing dude like I was thinking about
that last time like a fighting on the
car I don't have to worry about this
stupid rust spot yeah yeah you don't
want a car you don't you don't have rust
problem rent on your car yeah what about
your iPhone that all essential life
device surely you own that well sort of
when Apple Inc decides to change the
operating software sooner or later you
have to go along with what they have
selected Gmail is due to change its
overall look and functionality maybe for
the better but again eventually this
choice will not be yours either yeah I
don't want to design the software for my
gmail account I would prefer to let the
experts the the curators yeah allow them
to do that because here's here's how the
market works
Tyler the market works that if we hate
the thing then we move on to something
else Skype has had this problem recently
they forced people to upgrade to
whatever the new software system was and
then Microsoft got so many complaints
that they actually had to go back and
say okay we're gonna we're gonna allow
you to have this old version it's
different from the mobile version that's
how the market works because if you
don't like the thing you move on to the
the better thing now we we can talk
about how some some companies develop a
monopoly that's a different kind of
problem right
oh if it's YouTube it's not a true
monopoly because you could put something
we could put this video on Vimeo and and
so we could talk about maybe some of
these things should be considered public
utilities like Google or YouTube I don't
necessarily believe so but I think there
can be good arguments for that that's
completely different from the argument
he's making here for physical ownership
yes I would prefer the Gmail figures out
their interface instead of allowing me
to design their interface for them right
unless you're like Derek Siver's who has
their own email they're almost like
there's no server yeah but yeah but but
again the lake that's his preference
yeah and here's the thing dude is that
is a that is a you have to have the
knowledge and how to set that up a PDF
to afford that and you know Gmail this
example that they're using yes like
maybe we don't have full control over it
it's your point it's good we don't
because we don't understand how to make
a a mail service but it also makes it
more accessible like Gmail is free right
and if you don't like Gmail you can use
another Yahoo Hotmail or what are the
other ones
yeah but there are a bunch of other ones
yeah there are absolutely you know I
always I see people like with the cell
friends like in Cincinnati or though
Senseo are are calm there's plenty out
there
imagine the Internet of Things
penetrating our homes and more through
services like Amazon's Alexa kill Ryan
Nicodemus will have ovens and
thermostats that you set with your voice
that's pretty cool in a toilet in a
bathroom that periodically give you the
equivalent of a medical check-up not
true but okay yes you will still own the
title to your physical house but most of
the value in that home you will in
essence rent from outside companies or
in the case of municipal utilities the
government yeah yeah I do get my water
from the government
and and you know what that's okay
because I don't want to have to go to a
well every day yeah and and get the
water and then heat it up I would argue
that anything we think we own anyways I
mean it if anything on a long enough
time timeline is ephemeral right right
so I mean we really don't own anything
anyway man right it's all gonna go away
eventually I mean yeah we could pass it
down but I just argue that the the
concept of ownership it well let's
adjust that it's a concept and because
people accept the concept then then yes
ownership is a thing but ultimately I
mean it's yeah you're right it's all
borrowed yeah so I'm gonna put a shot if
you could put a link to this in the show
notes here I'll hand this over to you
now so you have it if you could put a
link to that podcast shown on the show
notes the the rest I'll refer goes on
but that's our bit of a rant on on
ownership versus access you know what I
am for both I want to own certain things
I want to have access to certain things
and I want that to change
over time sometimes I might want to own
a car but there may be a point in time
where I just want access to a car maybe
I want to stop owning the thing
altogether or I might want to own a
house or I might want to rent a house
that's access to out when we travel on
tour we have access to a room either
Airbnb or a hotel I don't wanna buy a
house right I go to Nashville for a week
right
you